hey what's up my name's samuel leeds i'm
a property investor and if you want to
invest in property if you want to make
money in property then really you need
to be subscribed to this youtube channel
because i'm talking regularly about
mistakes that i've made mistakes other
people have made and listen you can
either learn from other people's
mistakes or you can learn from your own
mistakes and
why would anybody in their right mind
learn from their own mistakes when you
can learn from somebody else's so the
very first question that comes up perry
talks about how he had 10 hmos
that he'd built up in 12 months and
lost everything
that's crazy and now asking a question
so you can now learn from perry's
mistakes damn i can learn from perry's
mistakes so i'm going to go through
right now and i'll be answering people's
questions uh we've got a guy here who's
saying that he's got a speech impediment
and he's struggling to speak to agents
on the phone so what i'm going to do i'm
taking your problems your challenges
your issues and i want to be sharing
about how you can be helped giving you
advice and try my best to see you win
the purpose of this whole youtube
channel is that you can win as a
property investor because you know what
i didn't want to work in a nine-to-five
job until i was 67 and then have a
shitty little pension and honestly you
know what the normal status quo of what
people believe about money go to
university get a job buy a house to live
and pay down the mortgage it's nonsense
so this is a little bit um you know the
way that i teach is a little bit
different but i'm very wealthy i've made
millions of pounds in property and now
i'm gonna be helping you with your
property journeys as well if you enjoy
my channel smash the like button that's
the very first thing you need to do go
hit like and let's get right down to
this so we're going to start with perry
perry says i had 10 hmos in 12 months
hooray and drawing covid but
my lifetime friend who is no longer a
friend
pushed me out of the company when i
traveled to thailand during the pandemic
to get married
lesson learned
never trust anyone in business until you
sign a contract
what wish i which i foolishly didn't do
because he was my friend
please everyone sign contracts i'm now
back to square one i'm currently
studying youtube until i until i earn
enough money to start again perry first
man i want to say my heart breaks for
you i'm so sorry that you basically got
robbed and stolen i've seen this happen
time and time again where people build a
company and they don't bother to
structure it properly um don't have
contracts maybe it was better to be in
his name because for whatever reason or
he just put the company in his name and
said yeah we do it together and you just
oh it's fine and then you got screwed um
so i i think the lesson is yeah number
one is always have a contract number two
is understand the law
i'm studying law right now online i'm
doing online courses and i'm studying a
learning law contract law
corporate law commercial law property
law not because i want to be a lawyer
but because it's so important to
understand how to read contracts so my
heart breaks for you and i'm sure as
annoying as
as it was i'm sure that you will take
that lesson i don't know how many
hundreds of thousands of pounds that
might have cost you it's heartbreaking
but go and be a stronger richer wiser
property investor as a result if there's
anything i can do to help then let me
know and
i hope to see you rebuild better and
stronger with better foundations and
screw that guy you know so
let that be a lesson to everybody else
you know i always say if you're gonna
hit the rocks at least be a lighthouse
to other people so
rough start see what else we've got
going on time lapses in london wondering
if you have any suggestions or tips that
i could use to help
as i struggle when talking to agents i
have aphasia which is speech and
language disability talking to many
people agents builders etc is going to
be the main issue for me is there a way
to work alongside other people who are
already in the area and help them look
after other properties instead any of
the suggestions would be greatly
appreciated if you have worked or
assisted with other people with similar
disabilities
um you know what everybody has strengths
and everybody has weaknesses and the
first thing is you need to be aware of
your strengths and weaknesses so i don't
know if you've heard of the swot
analysis s-w-o-t you can all do this now
if you're watching this video so write
down strengths weaknesses opportunities
and threats
and your strengths are what you've got
going for you so um you know maybe
you've got a bit of money maybe you've
got a bit of knowledge maybe you know
how to find good deals maybe your
strength is you're really good at
talking to people um so write down all
your strengths and be aware of your
strengths and then the w's weaknesses
what are your weaknesses it's good to be
aware of your weaknesses one of the
reasons people fail is because they're
actually overconfident they're not aware
of their weaknesses so your weaknesses
you've got a
speech impediment and then opportunities
what are the opportunities on the
horizon the deals the the things that
the ways to make money the opportunities
ahead of you and then threats
what are the threats that could stop you
succeeding in your business you know
maybe the threat could be your own
mindset maybe the threat could be lack
of funds maybe the threat could be
competitors you're going to auction keep
getting outbid so you need to be aware
of this so the first thing i want to say
to you is at least you're aware of your
weakness um if you've got a weakness
like you have and like everybody has
then what's the solution or you either
get better at that area and you become
better at it or if you can't maybe
you've got an actual disability you just
you're never going to be able to be a
great communicator
i mean you come right well um but then
yeah you want to team up with somebody
find a hire somebody
get someone in your team whether that be
an employee or whether they be a if you
can't afford an employee maybe you just
want to partner up with somebody um and
and fill those gaps so
that's my best advice to you i would
just hire someone hire someone that's a
really good speaker on the phone
communicator and they don't have to be
smart you can tell them what to do what
you want what you want to say and then
let them just go and and do the thing
same as me you know there's certain
areas where i'm quite weak
i'm very weak on admin so my paperwork
organization i'm rubbish so i when i
started out in business the very first
person i hired was it was an admin
assistant that could help me keep track
of all the paperwork filed everything
for me so um i hope that helps and can
you win even with the speech impediment
absolutely yes you can i just ran a
training program um a couple of weeks
ago and there was two kids on the front
row okay one sixteen one's eighteen
they're blind
can't see
but they were still finding deals making
money in property end values 110 on the
75 percent mortgage you're gonna pull
out eighty two thousand five
hundred and seven rounds yeah
nice
so crazy all right raz van gabriel what
are some of the risks of being over
leveraged what would happen if the value
of the house drops below the mortgage
will the bank come and take the house
force you to sell so they can cover
their mortgage um raz van no not unless
your mortgage term finishes and you need
to pay back the uh
the lender and you can't um but
generally speaking if you're in negative
equity i wouldn't worry about it too
much and let me put some context in this
first so let's say you buy a house for
200 000 pounds
and you get a mortgage for 150 000
pounds
and you've got 50 000 pounds
equity in the house that should deposit
that's your skin in the game
if the value of the house drops
to
125 000 pounds that means you're in
negative equity right the value of the
house is lesser than the mortgage
now as long as your mortgage turn it
doesn't suddenly end and you have to pay
back the mortgage because that would be
a problem but i mean generally speaking
when you take a mortgage on you you
might take a 25-year
uh 25-year loan you're not going to
you're not going to take a mortgage on
them um you know on a two year on a two
year term you might fix the rates for
two years
but
so so if it drops and your negative
equity does it really matter
you might feel
that it matters but why did you buy the
property for in the first place i know
why i buy properties as an investor i
buy properties to rent them out
to live off the rent
income
that doesn't change
the income doesn't change if you've got
a property i've had this i bought i
bought um some houses in birmingham
um around about 2009
and then the market dropped
and i didn't have much equity in the
houses it was a bit of a problem but i
thought actually i'm renting these
houses out on a room by room basis
making a thousand pounds a month profit
who cares that it's dropped in value
and i just sat on it enjoyed the rent
waited for it to bounce back up so
unless your mortgage term is about to
end they're not going to they're not
going to call in the calling the loan
what would they want to call in the loan
if you're a negative equity
you know
i mean all you need to think is this
when you buy a house
what's the cash flow the value is going
to go up and down but it doesn't
actually matter
the value goes up and you make a load of
money you refinance or sell
but as long as it's paying you cash flow
it doesn't matter it'll bounce back up
eventually that's my general thoughts
scott
scott says i currently work in a
reasonably well paid job i wanted to
start off my property investing
adventure
like that
as a side venture an adventure as a side
venture
until i can afford to be financially
free other than coming to your training
which i'm booked in march well done
what's the best to get the ball rolling
uh okay scott i'll probably say to get
the ball rolling
you want to have five friends
that are winning in property
so get get find a new circle man if you
if you've got if you're in a circle if
your friends and buddies are in property
you'll be in property if your friends
are financially free you'll be
financially free if your friends are all
just your current
employees working for 30 35 grand a year
and that's what they do then you're
probably the same thing so i'd start
going networking i'd start i'd be on
social media connecting with people
having coffees
um going out for drinks
with people that are winning in property
and then if you do that
that's a good start to get the ball
rolling you come into march on the
training respect and be ready to take
loads of action
and and take some risk
you know because people people don't
want to take any risk at all
but it's like well if you don't take any
risk
that all you want is security then
you'll have security but then you're not
going to have the upside of the the
adventure and the fun and the money that
comes with being an entrepreneur so be
ready to take some risks
all right sam bigger staff
just finished your deal selling course
really enjoyed it well done
i've quit my job now well done
going full-time property well done i'm
starting to code your source of a few
people one person wants me to find a few
rent to rent for him how much should i
charge for these sorts of deals
i'm going to give you the short answer
and i'm going to give you the long
answer the short answer is about three
grand
maybe we'll stop watching the video now
you've got your answer um longer answer
is
if you're selling rental rents
it really depends on the profit on the
rent to rent and also how much they're
having to put down anyway for things
like refurb deposit with a rent to rent
deal
the person that's investing in the
renter rent should be getting a 100
return on their investment within the
first 12 months so
if the cash flows a grand a month profit
and there's no deposit and there's no
refurb and it's just literally
a month's rent up front then you could
probably charge five grand or six grand
for the finders fee
if the profit is 500 pounds a month and
they're already gonna have to put down
six grand on deposit and refurb then
that's gonna take them a year to get
their money back anyway so really that
you're not gonna charge them anything
for that kind of deal so it depends on
the profitability of the deal be careful
packaging and selling rent to rents
though because some people see rent to
rents as like a magic passive income
where they won't need to do anything
they can just float in the ocean and get
their nice rent coming in from a rental
rent that was sourced by somebody but
realistically we know that a rent to
rent is a business so if you've got a
rent around it's a business right you
need to systemize it you need to take
care of it you need to run it as a
business not to say you need to be in
the business but you need to be on the
business and on top of things
so if you're selling a rent to rent make
sure you're selling it to someone that
understands it's a business and they're
going to have to run that business and
they know how to do that
but otherwise you'll have people paying
you three grand and then six months
later they're like oh i'm not making
much money on my rent around and up yeah
because you ran it wrong
because it's a business you need to
understand how to run it
for him
asan
love your content thank you i would like
to ask what are the most effective ways
to locate owners of a derelict property
derelict properties i would probably say
if you want to do derelict properties
direct to vendor
drive around man
drive around and look out for rundown
properties you can tell they're run down
because they're boarded up or they're
just overgrown you can't see them
because there's bushes and stuff and you
can just tell it's derelict it's
abandoned
and then you wanna
take a picture of it
write down the address
and then when you get home
you want to go to land registry
and you want to search the address you
pay three pounds and that will give you
the title deeds to who owns the property
you'll have their name and all their
details
search for them on linkedin and facebook
track them down and say hey
your house is just derelict man it's
just empty
i'd like to buy it
what can we do i'd like to take control
of it what can we do
have a conversation see what happens
peace out
[Music]
you